comment sont-ils arrivés là trois obus
de la Première Guerre mondiale ont été
retrouvées ce matin dans un fossé à
Tours le long du Cher près de l'aire
d'accueil des gens du voyage un
périmètre de sécurité à rapidement été
mis en place nécessitant l'évacuation de
plusieurs dizaines de riverains plus
d'explications avec Aurélie Renaud
trois obus d'artillerie de marine chaque
obus pèse plus de 300 kg les engins ont
été découverts par les régisseurs de
l'aire d'accueil des gens du voyage lors
de leur tour des lieux quotidiens ça a
été la surprise quand j'ai vu les points
je me suis dit ça c'est pas des bouts du
gaz et du coup
on a constaté que c'était que c'était
des obus et là on a fait passer
l'information est-ce que vous avez eu
pour vous au départ non c'était
surprenant de les voir là mais
aussitôt un périmètre de sécurité est
mise en place dans tout le quartier les
familles vivant sur l'aire d'accueil
évacuent les lieux on a pris les enfants
on a paniqué ben on est parti avec les
enfants sur la route on a monté David
parking le temps que à apprendre à
revenir il y avait moins de policiers et
ils nous ont dit que il y avait les
diminuers qu'ils allaient venir j'ai vu
qu'il y avait des gendarmes tout ça il
arrive du débat cuire
aujourd'hui puis apparemment c'est pas
c'est pas dangereux c'est pas risqué on
va dire selon les démineurs de la
Rochelle ces obus date de la première
guerre mondiale ils sont inhabituels par
leur grande taille plus d'un mètre et
par leur présence ici en Touraine car ce
sont des engins qu'on retrouve sur les
côtes car tirées depuis des bateaux les
dans un proviennent sans doute d'un
trafic de métaux les obus ont
certainement été refusés par l'acheteur
car trop dangereux et donc abandonné par
les trafiquants